peng shuai lo califica como un enorme
malentendido en sus primeras
declaraciones en meses a medios
occidentales la estrella china del tenis
dijo el diario deportivo francés
l'equipe que nunca acusó a nadie de
agresión sexual peng también negó haber
desaparecido tras las supuestas
acusaciones tras la preocupación por su
bienestar a nivel internacional cuando
no se le vio en público durante semanas
nunca dije que alguien me hubiera
agredido sexualmente de ninguna manera
nunca ha desaparecido es sólo que mucha
gente como mis amigos o personas del coi
me enviaron mensajes y era simplemente
imposible responder a tantos en un post
ahora borrado en su perfil de weibo
tengo a curso en noviembre a un antiguo
funcionario del partido comunista chino
de obligarla a mantener relaciones
cuando el equipo preguntó por qué había
desaparecido el post-punk dijo que
simplemente había querido borrarlo sin
dar más detalles después de tres semanas
de ausencia
penn fue vista finalmente en público en
un evento de tenis juvenil la asociación
de tenis femenino dijo que las imágenes
aún no a las preocupaciones por su
bienestar la ex número uno del mundo de
dobles dijo que era una chica normal y
que no quería más revuelo mediático en
torno al asunto también señaló que
dejaría de competir culpando a una
lesión de rodilla que a un prolongado
parón en el juego debido a la pandemia a
veces es difícil decir adiós y retirarse
aunque ya no participe en competiciones
profesionales siempre seré tenista la
entrevista se realizó bajo ciertas
condiciones
peng recibió la mayoría de las preguntas
por adelantado y se pidió al equipo que
publicara las respuestas sin comentarios
aunque pen habla un inglés prácticamente
fluido la entrevista se realizó en
mandarín